john bell et des frites et des showcases
chutant sadoine il est très bon raid
salé où ça va tu as bien bien bien je
suis content de te revoir dans un nouvel
épisode t'imagines si tu avais fait le
tout premier league
il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous ont dit
que jean ouest vous avez pris des
substances et du coup je précise c'est
bien de l'eau qui se trouve à
l'intérieur du café mais on est bien on
a bon vous raconte pas tout ce qu'on a
fait sur ce lit ensemble c'est mieux
youtube c'est pas vrai c'est moi soir
démonétisé la vidéo ce serait dommage
est ce que tu sais c'est quoi la
question qu'on va traiter aujourd'hui tu
m'as dit vite feltham c t'imagines si le
cannibalisme était fréquent alors
t'imagines si on était vraiment
cannibales dans le sens où l'heure si
c'était moi même aux sociétés quoi
accepter totalement est donc très bien
bon masi et ben c'est parti je suis
chaud t'imagines si ya pas encore de
génériques mais ça arrive s'il connaît
le cannibalisme était courant le
véganisme aurait encore plus de mal à se
faire entendre
il y aurait peut-être des comportements
agressifs qui découlerait la peur de soi
bouffer plus quelqu'un de votre
entourage se fasse bouffer ma question
sur quels critères porterait le prix
d'un individu les mêmes que pour les
animaux ou les stars sur la plus chère
perso je pense je serai prête à payer
cher pour bouffer du ryan gosling non je
rigole
ouais mon avis tu rigole pas pense parce
que ce serait un truc sauvage président
se serait civilisé quoi ça soit en recul
pro avec ta fourchettes couteaux
aujourd'hui on a adressé deux visions
genre quand tu vois le passé tu dis
[ __ ] les gens étaient violents et
qu'ils étaient des barbares machin mais
non en fait c'était jusqu'à leur mort
mais leurs règles et version longue et
du coup je fasse ces imposteurs de dire
si jean fonctionner différemment ce
serait l'anarchie ce serait la violence
final je pense ça serait juste cette
norme est de règle ça les différents le
prix des joueurs comme andy priaulx
nains par hector bas je pensais déjà
l'alimentation que l'humain a eu enfin
le mode de vie laly gènes de vie que
l'humain avec de son vivant c'est
effectivement je pense qu'elle aime être
complètement parasiter ou qui a des
virus ce qui a comme celle papouasie
nouvelle guinée qui a des prions dans le
south china vivent ça vaut zéro puisque
tu personne ne veut acheter zhang tian
mais je pense que vraiment on le vendra
pas seulement pas weeds noël singulière
faire tiens c'est pas très intéressante
urgent verrait bien des gens passer des
contrôles juste avant leur mort pour que
leur vie bandes soient vendus et que la
famille réduit là tu dois être une sorte
d'héritage
tu donnes ton corps à la science mais à
l'assiette à la semaine comme moi tu
donnes ton corps à l'assiette
si le cannibalisme était courant la vie
en elle même et le fait de sauver des
gens dans le besoin serait minime
pompiers sont hospitaliers etc
une personne gravement malades ou
accidentés serait plus facilement des
branches est pourri pour récupérer son
corps à des fins défunt mdr alimentaire
il appelle à vannes c'est ok il a fait
la bonne certaines personnes pourraient
être plus enviés que d'autres les
sportifs les obèses les gens en très
bonne santé
j'imagine déjà à rayons de magasins
proposant cette techno de viande corse
élevé en plein air peut-être
aurions-nous eu aussi d'autres croyances
peut-être sur yon de plus proche de
nouvelles religions et de me vendre de
spiritisme occidentale petits malins
manger certaines personnes ou des êtres
qui nous sont chères serait comme leur
rendre hommage ou leur donner une
seconde une utilité ou s'accaparer leur
force vitale un peu comme les aliens
dans district 9 il y aurait une nouvelle
forme de spiritisme occidentale manger
des gens qui me sont chers ce serait
leur rendre hommage ça ça existait déjà
chez les forêts je crois en papouasie
nouvelle guinée
ça c'est des gens qui sait les dernières
personnes qui me la maladie qu'on
appelle le courroux qui en fait une truc
genre de fêter ça vous voyez c'est ça
c'est une jour de vache folle en fait et
du coup c'est parce qu'il vous fait les
cerveaux des gens mais c'était un truc
funéraire est donc littéralement il y
avait une notion de respecter les morts
comme ce qu'ils proposent pour nous
peut-être qu'il aurait ça va peut-être
qu'on fait de l'enterrement serait suivi
d'une banale et rapide intervention des
banques est bavard tu va bouffer un
point également genre dentaires les
autres tu vois par exemple et ensuite
web fait cela avec ce qui reste de ton
corps tu as et le cannibalisme était
très courant le meurtre serait légal
mais pour éviter que la population se
meut certaine il y aurait des
réglementations par exemple
l'interdiction de manger les enfants
moi je pense pas que ce soit lié avec le
meurtre en fait si le fait de manger un
c'est pas forcément tu es l'humain je
sais pas allier tu vas justement chez
les forêts tu te dis pas les gens
d'affaires et les bouffes une fête sont
mortes ouais sur la crème du spécisme là
on n'aurait pas le même niveau que les
animaux quoi ouais alors ça c'est super
intéressant que tu râles et ça je pense
que effectivement forcément la création
d'une bulle de on y mange pas et une
bulle de ses hoquets de le manger comme
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui que les
animaux tu as un animal de compagnie je
mange pas le même animal et qui a été
élevé en élevage qui mange à sa faim tu
penses que suivant les humains ne
mangent pas tous genres gandhi on mange
pas paraguay et même à une certaine
catégorie au mélange des genres et chez
les jeunes genre les femmes on les mange
pas les hommes on les mange pas tous
qu'ils auraient sans doute en fait d'une
certaine forme de classification du nom
mangeable et du monde jeune je pense
tous aller on parlait de festin pour un
proche des familles et aux frères et où
c'est vrai que si nos animaux
domestiques
on ne mange pas on risquerait d'être
dans cette logique aussi tu avais clope
de proches nos proches on les mangeait
pas ouais je pense après ce serait la
première fois où j'arrive pour y avoir
de la nourriture qu'ils soient made in
china town ah oui alors l éviction
brutale population à un bon gars ils
vont envoyer du stock du 5 mai au haut
si le cannibalisme était très courant on
continuerait à manger des
croque-monsieur ces deux enjeux le plus
beau si le cannibalisme était courant on
aurait des mères porteuses qui
produirait des enfants sans les entités
élevé et engraissés dans des élevages
jusqu'à qu'il soit suffisamment gros
pour être abattus et manger ce qui est
peut-être aussi cette espèce de décalage
qu'on a entre animaux et viande si on
dit les cochons et du port on dit
vaches et du boeuf est ce que tu sais on
a en fait on fait un lien indicible
disposition vraiment entre le l'animal
et puis le produit que ça donne millions
d'heures on dit pas on y va j'ai une
vache mais aussi attend 10 g du boeuf
comme si c'est une matière qui sortait
de nulle part et donc peut-être
effectivement à une production du vin
spécial se seraient pas des uv du coup
les amèneraient pas des mères porteuses
quoi parce que tu as auprès des maires
ouais c'est ça la production de viande
se serait tu es et tu les usines wise et
que les mêmes mots que tu as dans
l'agroalimentaire c'est pas du tout
n'était pas la mission dont tu parles de
bien belles vaches combat qui attend on
a trouvé un moyen de donner du job à des
gens un moyen de résoudre des problèmes
de nutrition
enfin je veux dire peut-être en parler à
nos politiques c'est kyle massey des
monnaies courantes je n'hésiterai pas à
goûter les eaux tant il est à croquer el
taief les bons mecs
est ce que ça t'a plu s'écoute merci
beaucoup pour vos réponses étaient hyper
intéressant pas mal de trucs ça a ouvert
pas mal de trucs de discussions etc
la prochaine question c'est celle là
pour le prochain épisode la question
c'est imagine si on pouvait respirer
sous l'eau et - invité sera viviane de
la chaîne syllabus merci à tous et gros
bisous mais aussi le tirage au sort de
la personne qui a gagné cette magnifique
boîte de jeu t'imagines si le nom
apparaît ici à l'écran bravo
félicitations tu peux envoyer un message
privé avec ton adresse et je te l'envoie
et le jeu continue japon en fait je fais
gagner le jeu genre on va prendre une
des questions qui sera dans l'épisode
sera tiré au sort et la personne qui a
écrit d'accord mais gagne un jeu est-ce
que tu as passé un bon mais à chaque
fois au muc ait le temps où le bât
version correcte de la mater la pastèque
ou mucus les noms de recettes peuvent
être très drôle
ah bah oui le [ __ ] mais qu'en plus on
s'arrête juste au moment où il ya
l'aspirateur parfait
un jeu film je suis déjà en retard sur
mon retard